8月11本投稿中登録者90万人目指して
ますチャンネル登録よろしくです8月31
日は6時間バンカラ生配信みんな見に来て
ね
[音楽]
私は最強の母親キリコそしてこの子が息子
の天才小学生ヨネスケ
さすがに夜ご飯少なすぎだろう
ので
ちょっくら奪ってきます
[音楽]
警察ですか今すぐ来てください
晩御飯
[音楽]
逃げないとおい
待て待て
窃盗の罪で
対応する
望むところよちょっと
待て
所長
[音楽]
君は素晴らしい
身体能力を持っている
その力を正義に使いなさいは君は
警察官になりなさい
[音楽]
[拍手]
警察官として任命する
[音楽]
[拍手]
おい俺はお前を認めてないからなでも私
警察官なんてやりたくないわよ
お前何言ってんだよそれじゃあ
逮捕になるな君にはついてるんだから運が
良かったと思う
[拍手]
羊を取った犯人が立てこもりをしている
模様地球へ向かうように早速仕事
だ
俺は綺麗に失敗してこの様だよ金をよこせ
俺に任せろ
おい次はないと思う
[音楽]
聞かないこれじゃ中にも入れないじゃない
か
何しに来たお前も人質になりに来たか
はいこれで仕事は終わりね
[音楽]
犯人を勇敢に捕まえた
麻上慶子を表彰する
[音楽]
[拍手]
ではね
お金がちょう
[音楽]
いただきます
今日の食事は豪華だね
逮捕するとお金がもらえるのよ何でも好き
なもの買ってあげるわね最高じゃお母さん
頑張ってもっちのロンです
よし2人は今日はパトロールしました
[拍手]
絵がパトロールで必要なことは人を見た目
で判断しないことただ優秀な警察官は
雰囲気や空気で止まって
怪しいから大砲
おいちゃんと調査してから逮捕しろ海が
なかったらどうするんだ本当ですよすい
ませんね見た目で判断するのはよくないっ
ておいもっとゲームおいそいつ指名手配犯
だぞよく捕まえたな
[音楽]
よくやったじゃないか
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
[拍手]
血糖剤で逮捕よお金がもらえる
来た来た
すいませんでした
仲良くしましょう
そういうことだったらこちらも
[拍手]
喧嘩じゃないよ
そしてこのイケメンちゃんは
職務質問です僕たちよ
[音楽]
あんたちょっと来なさい
あんたがやったんでしょ何のことですか
[音楽]
それ誰ですか私女たち関係ないですよ
あんたがやったことにしなさい
サーモン
認めるので命だけは許してください
はいそれでよし
いやーよくやった
短期間でこれだけの犯人を捕まるのすごい
うちの人の評価も爆上がりだ
[音楽]
し進させる
拍手
[拍手]
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
ほら面会よ
お母さん何もしてないの
頑張ってすぐ戻るからね
[音楽]
早く会いたい
よ
[音楽]
ね
[拍手]
[音楽]
私系部門偉い
肩も見なさいはい
お前ちょっといいか
お前だ
罪のない人間に常に押し付けやがって俺は
全部見てるぞそうやって
罪を作って金を稼ごうんだろう
全部知ってるぞ全部所長に言ってるからだ
から何私の方がいないんだからあんた黙っ
てくれない
警察官としてこの鍛え上げた力でお前を
バカバカにして
おいどうしたのよ
お母さんお金たくさん儲かったんだね
スイッチ買ってよ約束でしょ
あんたこれ誰のお金だと思ってんの
欲張り台に逮捕するわよ
ハーゲンダッツいっぱい買いたいから
たくさん対応してたくさん稼がないとね
[拍手]
触らないでください
警察の捜査よ
協力しなさい
おい何してんだお前口答えすんなよ
操作の妨害に逮捕するんですよ
[音楽]
お金だちょー
どうしたんだよ
裏ではかなりの悪女を働いてるんです
あんたがやったことにしなさい
さもなくばそれを指摘したら
なんだって
今日の行動を政府に報告したところに国
から懸賞金1億円がつけられた
そこで大捜査隊を行う
丘上を作戦に向けて情報を片っ端から用意
しよう
金と権力に溺れるとはな
我ら警察が正義のことを
捕まえて市民の安全を守るんだ
今日も適当なやつ捕まえで稼ぐぞ
ハーゲンダッツ
[音楽]
あんたたちねま全員倒してやりましょうか
[拍手]
お母さん
助けて悪いが息子には人質になってもらっ
た
息子を帰りなさい君は数々の犯罪を貸して
きた人質なんか法に触れるが最後
あれと権力に溺れ
息子にも背を向けてそれでも
楽しめるのか
[拍手]
お母さん
逃げて私間違ってたわ
遅紙子
さよならここで終わりちゃん
お前
[音楽]
ら出てる
[拍手]
[音楽]
一緒に
良かったねんだよ指名手配の鐘は
他の警察官たちはいいの本当はダメだけど
俺この書で一番偉い
の金と権力
[音楽]
[拍手]
あんた帰るわよ
ちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしく最初は
じゃんけん
チョキまたねチャンネル登録
[音楽]